Macaques in Japan use coins to buy vending
machine snacks.
The Dutch village of Giethoorn has no roads;
its buildings are connected entirely by canals
and footbridges.
Beijing, Seoul and Tokyo all mean 'capital'
in their respective languages.
The youngest Pope was 11 years old.
All blue-eyed people are mutants.
The first ones appeared as recently as 5,000
years ago.
More than 90% of all the blackcurrants grown
in Britain go into Ribena.
The International Space Station has cost more
than 30 times its own weight in gold.
There are 4,800 species of frog in the world
but only one of them goes 'ribbit'.
The amount of water on Earth is constant,
and continually recycled over time: some of
the water you drink will, at one point, have
passed through a dinosaur.
Almost all the botox in the world is made
in a single factory in Ireland.
Every human being starts out life as an arsehole:
it's the first part of the body to form in
the womb.
Mushrooms are more closely related to humans
than to plants.
Cocks don't have cocks.
In 97% of bird species, the males don't have
penises.
3% of pet owners give Valentine's gifts to
their pets on Valentine's Day.
At least 109 journeys between adjacent London
Tube stations are quicker to walk.
It costs more to make the cardboard box that
Shredded Wheat comes in than it does to make
the Shredded Wheat itself.